en este vídeo quiero hacer un repaso de
todas las propiedades lindas y
asombrosas que hemos visto acerca de los
triángulos así que vamos a dibujar un
montón de triángulos y acordarnos de qué
se trataba cada cosa vale bueno déjenme
empezar dibujando un triángulo por acá
un triángulo por acá y vamos a
acordarnos de que eran las media tristes
van entonces voy a ponerle por aquí
media trizas me día tristes
bueno cuando empezamos a hablar acerca
de media tristes dijimos que eran rectas
perpendiculares a un segmento que
pasaban por su punto medio entonces aquí
las media tristes se verían más o menos
algo así aquí tendríamos una media tris
más o menos acá tenemos otra media tris
algo así no es algo quedó tan
perpendicular más o menos como algo así
y finalmente por acá tenemos una tercera
media triz entonces son rectas que
parten este segmento a la mitad este
segmento a la mitad y este segmento a la
mitad y además son perpendiculares a los
lados bueno lo que platicamos de esas
media tristes es que esas pasan por un
mismo punto si son concurrentes es decir
las tres pasan por un mismo punto y de
hecho eso es algo que va a seguir
pasando en los demás conceptos que
repasemos entonces son rectas que pasan
por un mismo punto y algo interesante es
que ese punto donde las tres pasaban era
un punto que era equidistante a los tres
vértices del triángulo a este punto de
ahí le llamábamos el círculo centro
porque era el centro de una
circunferencia con radio la distancia
hacia los vértices entonces más o menos
podíamos trazar algo así ya ver si sale
más o menos algo así quizás un poco más
para acá
bueno más o menos es la idea y ese punto
de ahí este punto de ahí le llamábamos
el circo un centro entonces le voy a
poner por aquí que es el circo un centro
si un centro le llamábamos así porque el
centro de una circunferencia
circunscrita o bien de un circo un
círculo circo un círculo
y a estas tres distancias que eran
iguales a cualquiera de ellas le
podíamos llamar el círculo radio vale
porque justo es el radio de esta
circunferencia entonces este de acá se
llamaba círculo radio
un radio
muy bien entonces tenemos el círculo es
decir un centro y el cirque un radio
bueno eso es con respecto a media
tristes pero después platicamos de otras
rectas importantes quedan las bisectriz
es voy a pintar otro triángulo por acá
algo más o menos de este estilo vale y
aquí en el caso de las bisectriz es le
voy a poner por aquí bisectriz es
tristes teníamos que eran rectas que
partían los ángulos a la mitad o sea que
los viste cavan entonces en este dibujo
nos quedarían más o menos como algo así
entonces me quedaría una más o menos así
donde este ángulo es igual a este ángulo
de acá voy a pintar otra en color
naranja más o menos como algo así creo
que me puede quedar más bonita como algo
así entonces ahí este ángulo es igual
este ángulo de acá y bueno la tercera la
tercera también pasaba por este punto de
intersección porque también nos pudimos
convencer de que las tres se
interceptaban en un mismo punto y a ese
punto de ahí le llamábamos el in centro
porque ahora era centro de una
circunferencia inscrita al triángulo
inscrita porque está por dentro y para
mostrar eso lo que mostrábamos antes era
que ese punto era equidistante a los
tres lados o sea que si tratábamos la
perpendicular para acá la perpendicular
para acá
y la perpendicular para acá más o menos
para acá entonces esas tres
perpendiculares median lo mismo vale más
o menos el círculo nos quedaría digamos
algo así más o menos algo así pasa por
esos tres puntos a ese círculo le
llamábamos el en círculo del triángulo
si no quiero dibujar otro círculo éste
le llamamos el insee culo
círculo del triángulo al punto donde
pasan las directrices le llamamos el in
centro el in centro y finalmente a la
distancia del punto a cualquiera de los
lados a estar acá le llamamos el
inflación
radio muy bien pero con las directrices
también pasaba otra cosa interesante y
que tenía que ver con esta configuración
de acá déjame ver cómo hago el
triangulito lo voy a poner por acá más o
menos algo de este estilo va y aquí le
voy a poner nombre a los vértices
entonces aquí voy a ponerle aquí voy a
ponerle ve y aquí voy a ponerle c
entonces lo que teníamos era una
configuración más o menos así si aquí
tratábamos la bisectriz imagínate que de
veras es bisectriz o sea que este ángulo
es igual este ángulo de acá y a este
punto le llamamos b llamamos de entonces
probamos que la razón ave entre b d lo
voy a poner aquí arriba ave entre v de
entre vez de era igual a la de hace
entre c de hace entre cd ya esto de aquí
le llamábamos el teorema de la bisectriz
bisectriz
muy bien entonces esto es con respecto a
bisectriz es seguimos después explorando
y empezamos a hacer otras cosas y
empezamos a platicar acerca de otras
rectas que llegan a los puntos medios
pero ahora van de los vértices a los
puntos medios ya esas rectas les
llamábamos las medianas déjame trazar un
triángulo morado por aquí y déjame
ponerle aquí arriba ese lado que era un
poco chueco déjame ponerlo aquí arriba
que ahora vamos a hablar de las medianas
medianas las medianas también pasaban
por los puntos medios pero a diferencia
de las media tristes no tienen por qué
ser perpendiculares más bien van de un
vértice al punto medio opuesto entonces
digamos aquí tenemos este punto medio
en este punto medio y este punto medio
de acá entonces las medianas eran estas
rectas la que va de aquí a acá la que va
de aquí a acá y la que va de aquí a acá
y también mostramos que esas tres
concurrían en un único punto vale pero
además con las medianas pasaban otras
cosas interesantes este punto de acá que
era el punto donde concurrían
vamos centro hoy de centro hoy de o bien
también se le conoce como grab y centro
pero bueno resultaba que este centro hoy
de lo podíamos pensar como el centro de
masa de este triángulo es decir si fuera
un triángulo así rígido y lo pudiéramos
aventar y el que gire entonces el
triángulo giraría alrededor de este
punto de acá más o menos sería como el
punto de masa el punto el centro de masa
del triángulo vale pero eso bueno eso lo
puedes ver después en cosas en clases de
física y en cursos que tengan que ver
con eso pero también vimos otras
propiedades geométricas interesantes
resulta que esas tres medianas que pasan
por el centro hoy de dividen al
triángulo en seis triángulos y mostramos
que las áreas las áreas de esos seis
triángulos serán todas iguales eran
todas iguales y además probamos una cosa
bien interesante vimos que el centro y
de estaba a dos terceras partes de la
mediana yendo del vértice al punto medio
es decir que esto estaba en razón dos a
uno eso es lo mismo verdad si estás a
dos tercios entonces esto de aquí arriba
lo de abajo es un tercio entonces divide
a la mediana en razón 2a
muy bien ahora algo que más o menos
tenía que ver con medianas pero no tanto
era el triángulo medial voy a dibujar
por aquí otro triángulo voy a agarrar la
herramienta de recta porque si no no me
salen derechitos entonces otra cosa
interesante que tenía que ver con puntos
medios era el triangulo medial que
consistía en tomar los puntos medios del
triángulo y unirlos para acá para acá y
para acá
más o menos y lo que sucedía es que esta
figura cumplía varias cosas interesantes
al trazar ese triángulo medial el
triángulo nos quedaba dividido en cuatro
triángulos y esos cuatro triángulos
todos eran congruentes esté aquí esté
aquí era congruente a éste de acá con
durante este de acá y congruente este de
acá y además probamos otras cosas
interesantes por ejemplo que este lado
era paralelo a este lado que este lado
de acá era paralelo al de aquí al de acá
y finalmente que este otro lado este de
aquí si no se ve muy bien déjame agarrar
otro color que este de acá era paralelo
a este de acá vale además eran
triángulos de la misma área y cumplían
otras cosas interesantes pero todo todo
tenía que ver con que estos cuatro
triángulos eran congruentes vale
entonces estoy acá es el triángulo
triángulo
triángulo medial ok eso también estaba
interesante y finalmente terminamos
nuestra plática hablando acerca de las
alturas entonces déjame poner por acá
las alturas con este color escrituras a
alturas de un triángulo entonces aquí lo
que hacíamos era tomar el triángulo y
dibujar dibujar voy a trazar un poco más
para acá dibujar las tres alturas es
decir las rectas que eran
perpendiculares a los lados y que
pasaban por un vértice entonces ahora
tendríamos algo más o menos de este
estilo la altura para acá sería más o
menos algo así llega con un ángulo de 90
grados la altura para acá sería más o
menos algo así y la altura para acá
sería algo así y también logramos
convencernos de que esas tres alturas se
interceptaban en un mismo punto vale
este de aquí el recto estoy aquí es
recto este de aquí es recto y a ese
punto por donde pasaban las tres alturas
le llamábamos el [ __ ] centro
todo centro
y cierto centro corto centro punto
centro de el triángulo muy bien entonces
espero que este repaso ayude a aclarar
de qué se tratan cada una de estas cosas
y nos ayude a no confundirnos entre
ellas espero que te haya gustado y nos
vemos en siguientes vídeos